bonjour à toutes l'équipe ça va bien
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
en ordre de bataille sur le front des
retraites Elisabeth borne et son
gouvernement ont lancé les hostilités la
première ministre a détaillée cet
après-midi son projet de réforme est
confirmé ce que redoutait les syndicats
l'âge légal de départ à la retraite sera
allongé dès le premier septembre de
trois mois par an de 62 ans actuellement
il passera ainsi à 63 ans et 3 mois en
2027 à la fin du quinquennat puis 64 ans
en 2030 les carrières longues
continueront à partir plus tôt 60 ans
par exemple pour quelqu'un qui a
commencé à travailler à 16 ans en
contrepartie le gouvernement veut mettre
en place une retraite minimum à 8 5% du
SMIC soit 1200 euros par mois un montant
jugé trop juste par certains il y a 78%
de français aujourd'hui qui sont
fondamentalement opposées
sur l'âge parce que c'est important de
savoir quel âge
dans cette réforme il y a plein de
négociations qui ont été ouvertes
concernant la durée de cotisation le
gouvernement maintient les 43 annuités
mais accélère cet objectif devait être
atteint en 2035 il devra finalement
l'être en 2027 nous allons fermer la
plupart des régimes spéciaux de retraite
existants c'est une question d'équité
les syndicats se concertent ce soir sur
la suite à donner aux annonces du
gouvernement ces derniers jours à
Matignon à la sortie de leur
consultation avec Elisabeth borne ils
ont déjà prévenu j'ai dit à la première
mise qu'elle avait réalisé un exploit ça
faisait 12 ans que l'ensemble des
organisations syndicales pays ne s'était
pas uni contre une réforme Elizabeth
borne était notamment accompagnée de son
ministre du Travail Olivier dussobe
c'est lui le vrai artisan de cette
réforme et Olivier du soft peut se
vanter d'être le seul ministre à avoir
un jour traité le président de la
République de renard c'était en
septembre 2014 Emmanuel Macron tout
juste nommé ministre de l'Économie avez
évoqué à la radio des ouvriers illettrés
des abattoirs Gad vous vous souvenez
Olivier du socle l'avait aussi tôt
traités le jour même à l'Assemblée le
lui avait dit lui avait dit je suis
député de l'Ardèche ma mère est ouvrière
sans diplôme et ce matin vous l'avez
insulté lorsqu'il était venu sur ce
plateau au mois d'avril Emmanuel Macron
avait reconnu que ceux qui
commenceraient à travailler à 20 ans
travaillerait 45 ans c'était alors quand
à la borne était fixée à 45 ans ce que
c'est moi sans jeu de mots ce sera 44
ans donc c'est mieux mais cela reste
injuste et on en revient toujours à ce
constat que la France
c'est le marché du travail sur lequel on
entre le plus tard et où on sort le plus
tôt la France c'est le pays où on paye
le plus d'impôts où on est le plus des
gens et en fait c'est toujours le bordel
on veut jamais avancer on veut jamais
rien faire moi je veux bien qu'on en
débattre moi je veux bien qu'on en
débattre moi je veux bien qu'on débattre
tous les jours des sujets mais il y a
toujours des gens comme toi pour que tu
es dans la colle en permanence la
première ministre qui attendent et
ensuite rendu hommage à Ariel Boulin
Prat et Bertrand Renard des chiffres et
des lettres la CFDT l'une ça la CFTC la
CPE
[Rires]
et bien contre toute attente j'ai 11
lettres avec des cuscutants
de plantes cultivées
et que ça date de 1968 et bien il faut
faire attention de ne pas percer ce
mobilier on en connaît une qui a vécu
quelques déconvenues en rentrant chez
elle hier soir
j'étais malade avec le dîner de Soraya
limite je me suis transformé en
montgolfière je sais pas comment j'ai
fait pour pas m'en voler
moi je pense pas que ce sont mes épices
moi j'ai mis que des produits frais donc
c'est sûr que c'est pas mon tajine qui
lui a donné
[Musique]
vous êtes beau
en forme
oui oui
la nature c'est une jolie peau oui merci
prenez bien le soleil merci c'est gentil
de nous rassembler à la télé
on a fait l'émission
[Applaudissements]
qui est avec nous voilà il est là alors
Louis adio maire de Perpignan
bonsoir bonsoir Louis oui vous allez oui
oui bonsoir vous allez bientôt vous
coucher vous êtes en pyjama
tranquille alors moi je me suis bien en
mécanicienne et j'ai mes officiers sont
avec moi Harold vous êtes en je suis
capitaine je suis capitaine du Big
Redouane en bataillon qui a participé au
débarquement en Normandie et Yves aussi
appartient à ce à cette même compagnie
tout à fait je suis major donc
moi je suis caporal
c'est vous qui conduisez la jeep
aujourd'hui
[Musique]
un slogan nazi en plein direct qu'elle
qualifiera de simples erreurs de
prononciation
mais quelques années plus tard Dieudonné
enchaîne les polémiques l'homme tient
alors des propos jugés antisémites et
négationnistes sont spectacle fait
l'objet d'une interdiction et il est
condamné à plusieurs reprises par la
justice j'ai dérangé beaucoup de monde
et je vais continuer à le faire mais
aujourd'hui dans une lettre ouverte
publiée par Israël magazine Dieudonné
tient pour la première fois à présenter
ses excuses envers la communauté juive
j'ai parfois été trop loin et fait
preuve d'outrans de provocation déplacée
pour toutes ces fautes et excès je
demande pardon un mois plus tard elle
récidive sur Instagram
50 pages et Anne Frank me paraît
seulement immoral une petite débauchée
la publication provoque un tollé le haut
synonyme de détritus qui se transforme
parfois en insultes ordure oui regarde
comment je vais le remettre à sa place
là où lui il voit des Noirs moi je vois
des Français exactement
[Applaudissements]